Alright, so we've just seen,
especially in that last quiz, how to
evaluate an expression or a statement
in in an environment,
but we've been assuming that the environment,
which I said is kind of like the world,
comes pre-prepared, but what if we
want to build a new world?
What if we want to set the values of variables?
What if I want to determine what the current temperature is?
Here I've written 2 code snippets,
1 in Python and 1 in JavaScript
that do the same thing, and both of them
extend or create an environment.
They make a bigger, richer world that has
new bindings of values to variables.
Here in Python, we assign the value zero
to the variable x, and then we're going to
print out x + 1, that'll be 1,
and over here in JavaScript, we use a
var statement to introduce the variable x and assign it the value zero,
and then we write out onto the web page x + 1,
which in an incredible surprise move will also be 1.
We're going to want to handle
statements like these in our JavaScript
interpreter in order to build our web browser.
So let's test our knowledge of assignment.
statements with a brief quiz.
So here I've written a fragment of Python code
that's going to print out results to the screen
based on these 2 print statements in myfun.
What I would like you to do is to determine
which of the following outputs
could actually be produced by this program
and try to work through it in your head,
and this quiz is multiple, multiple choice.
Check each box that corresponds to a
string that could be printed out
if you were to run this program in the Python interpreter.